this is my time to do a real rock and
roll album a true rock and roll not
country at all so we're going to have
some classic singers and some classic
songs and some originals and I'm calling
it rockstar I thought why not of course
because I'm a rock star now you are a
rock star now own that title
there are certain myths that pop up that
seem to follow artists around so I
wanted to do a little segment we call
Dolly do or Dolly don't and bust some of
these myths ready is it true that you
sleep with full hair full makeup most
nights when you're on the road I always
wear my makeup and I always if I don't
have my own hair fixed I have a wig on a
lampshade or something because you never
know when you're gonna have to exit a
building so I try to stay ever ready
just in case is it true that you have an
entire room dedicated to your wigs and
hair pieces uh well I have a closet that
has
makeup is really just a room for that
type of stuff
okay wig trunks on the road I have
trunks made that you'll carry like three
to three to five wigs that you have if
you're doing shows it's just so handy
with one of the wildest rumors that
you've heard about yourself oh heavens
I've heard everything there was one time
in Inquirer magazine that my boobs were
so heavy that they had broken my back
down and that I couldn't get up that I
was going to be crippled for the rest of
my life and I thought well they are big
and they are heavy but I can still get
around and I'm doing all right